in the morning we heard how you know big
data and real-time decision-making can
help us do better science in the field
of astronomy so now we go to switch
gears completely and talk about how real
high decision-making can not only help
us do better science I think in but also
to well to stop me and ask kind of
whatever questions you have about the
material I'm going to cover and we're
gonna sort of have an afternoon talking
about earthquakes and we're doing this
in two installments so first of all I'm
going to try and give you an overview of
what I think is that by far the most
interesting aspect of earthquakes which
is earthquake early warning and sort of
what is the purpose of this what are the
goals try and give you sort of a basic
overview of how we do this what what are
the the sort of fundamental steps that
we need to go through when it comes to
dealing with large amounts of data and
then after the break
[ __ ] I who's one of the graduate
students a very senior graduate student
I might say in my group and who is
responsible for what's the most exciting
aspect of what we're doing right now I
think which is building a global seismic
Network using smartphones using the
smartphones in your pocket and so he I'm
going to give an overview of that
project but he's going to really talk
about some of the nitty-gritty and get
into the details of how that works we
figured that might be the kind of
material that would be good fodder for
this group so that's kind of the game
plan so say please um
stop either me or [ __ ] I at any point
and will be happy to go off in some
other direction if that's what would be
useful okay so I'm going to give this
sort of overview talk
so a warning when you need it earthquake
smartphones and streaming data to to
project names which I realize are
confusing for many people but you're
going to fully understand the difference
between the two and by the time I'm done
one is shakealert and one is my shake
and that the difference between these
two is really critical in my opinion
shakealert is uses traditional seismic
networks it's a proven technology and
we're working very rapidly towards
having a public early warning system
using shake alert my shake is a research
project it's not a proven technology but
we're very excited about the potential
that might shake that my shake might
have okay so where why would a warning
be useful well just to kind of set the
stage a little bit right now here in
California everybody is more than aware
of how how much improvement is needed in
our warning capabilities generally in
any sense for for natural hazard type of
events this is an image from the fires
in Northern California there was for
those of you who weren't in the state at
the time it was a real issue these fires
broke out in the middle of the night
they there was widespread failure in
warning people about these fire storms
that were just burning through areas
just north of here and so there was a
number of fatalities as a result of that
and that then of course led more
recently to the mudslides that mudslides
being due to fires in Southern
California in the fall as well and again
there was an issue with alerting and and
we saw that the alerting systems that we
have failed and again the failure here
is in actually getting the warning out
to people and of course we're going to
be talking about how you generate
warnings but this is about this all fits
into the same question of how do you
gather real-time continuous data process
it in a way that's useful and then use
it to provide warnings to people getting
a little more close to home this is a
picture of an office after the
Northridge earthquake in Southern
California
this is just to remind people that while
we are most for the most part in
buildings that we do not expect are
going to collapse here in California at
least most buildings are are not
expected to collapse you can fully
expect every building to look like this
okay you should be very concerned about
these big heavy-duty ceiling tiles that
are above your heads if we have an
earthquake right now there's a good
chance that they will come down and
they'll do serious injury so even if the
building is not going to collapse
knowing that the earthquake is happening
is about to happen is enough time to
move get down between these chairs and
actually significantly reduce the impact
of the earthquakes that's the idea of
earthquake early warning this is a image
from the Napa earthquake so this is very
close to home a couple of years ago now
very small earthquake this is just a
magnitude six okay in a wood frame
building one of the best types of
buildings to be in and yet still the
fireplace like this fell and collapsed
and killed somebody looking more
globally while we're in good shape when
it comes to buildings not collapsing in
California we're not in good shape when
it comes to buildings not collapsing in
many other earthquake prone parts of the
world this comes from Nepal from a
couple of years ago again or quite used
to seeing images like this when we see
earthquakes in some parts of the world
Taiwan even the places where we do have
good building codes Taiwan still there
are significant lapses in terms of how
they're enforced and these collapsed
apartment buildings were the result of
that and then finally it's just amazing
how many people need a warning this guy
has got his head in this crack in the
road and no doubt created by the Napper
earthquake in the day after the Napa
earthquake very good chance to be enough
to shut while there were aftershocks
obviously not an insignificant
probability there would be an aftershock
right now this is not the situation you
want to be in and while this is kind of
amusing the point here is that when you
start to think about the many situations
in which you would actually be in harm's
way and
would be useful to have a warning
there's many of them okay so oh and I
have one more sorry I forgot about this
one so this comes from Mexico City this
comes from the magnitude 7 earthquake in
Mexico City last year which is you you
probably know we did a lot of damage it
caused a fair number of fatalities and
Mexico City has an early warning system
okay so I'm going to show you a video
Mexico has an early warning system and
the siren that you can hear in the
background well in this video is
actually is the early warning system
going off so the early warning siren has
already sounded when this video starts
we couldn't figure out the audios
so this this is a game to make the point
that the three significant time
available when it comes to having a
warning so even though this actual
warning the sirens only went off when
the shaking had actually started in
Mexico City but the building's
themselves didn't collapse for many tens
of seconds after the shaking had started
so again the point is that there can be
significant amount of warning when I say
significant I'm talking about tens of
seconds potentially up to a minute or so
worth of warning so that's so how's that
possible well I'm going to illustrate
that with this this cartoon animation
but it's showing the biggest earthquake
that we have to worry about here in the
San Francisco Bay Area this is the
magnitude 8 earthquake on the San
Andreas Fault it's starting up here at
the northern end were of course down
here it's gonna rupture all the way this
is the rupture frontier the brown broad
brown line it's gonna come all the way
down the San Andreas Fault that's what
makes it a magnitude 8 the circles
represent the energy that's radiating
out from the fault the yellow are the P
waves they travel fastest but they don't
contain that much energy so they usually
don't do very much damage there's just
kind of oh so right about now is when we
would know this earthquake was underway
and this is a big earthquake so we would
feel this we would know that this was an
earthquake but we wouldn't know whether
this was just a relatively small
moderate earthquake a magnitude 4 like
the one we had a few weeks ago or
actually just the beginning of a much
bigger earthquake the fact that the
shaking would still be going on this
relatively light shaking would still be
going on
I would now know this was a big
earthquake you guys may not be quite so
sure but it's not until the S wave
arrives which is the red circle that you
really start to feel the shaking okay
and it's the S wave energy that does
most of the damage so now this building
would really be shaking we would all
know that we are in a really big
earthquake but again we still would not
know the full scale of this event
because
it's not until the S wave energy from
the closest section of the fault arrives
that most of the damage is done
so the rupture front is still only
reached this bar is going to come all
the way down here and it's when the
rupture passes San Francisco here and
that energy radiates across to us here
in Berkeley that most of the damage
actually occurs so that's still another
20-30 seconds from now so this is to
illustrate the concept behind early
warning big earthquakes can have
significant amounts of time between when
they start and when the damage is done
and so the idea behind earthquake early
warning is you use sensors distributed
throughout the earthquake prone region
to detect the beginnings of the
earthquake push out a warning to people
and then of course you have to continue
to update this information as time
proceeds yeah exactly you know sort of
the the the seismic waves they travel
that what are the speed of sound and the
the information travels at the speed of
light is that exactly that kind of
concept and you can see here that we're
talking about maybe up to a minutes
worth of warning okay so that's the
concept that's why earthquake early
warning okay so why is it useful I
usually have to make this argument maybe
I don't need to do that today but I'm so
used to it I'm just going to make the
case why is earthquake early warning
useful well the first is to reduce the
impact even in California where we have
good buildings to reduce the impact from
the injuries that I already talked about
I already talked about the effect of an
office building here but here's some
actual numbers in the Loma Prieta
earthquake which was the last major
damaging earthquake in the Bay Area more
than 50% of the injuries were linked to
Falls and then in Northridge more than
50% of injuries were due to non
structural hazards that's these ceiling
lighting fixtures and things like that
falling on people so more than half of
the injuries the point here is more than
half of the injuries are due to these
kinds of hazards so if everybody
received a few seconds warning isn't and
if everybody then took a pro protects
zhan then you could reduce the number of
injuries by about 50% and that is a
significant reduction in the impact of
earthquakes even in these earthquakes
which were just sort of moderate
earthquakes they were not really big
earthquakes and by the scale of what we
were expecting
even in these earthquakes in Northridge
at least rather and the total cost of
the injuries alone is about two to three
billion dollars so the amount of warning
time you get depends on the origination
of the earthquake is it reasonable to
sit it originates at one end or the
other of the palm torquay it originated
anywhere right so first of all yes the
amount of warning time is is determined
by your distance from the epicenter of
the earthquake because we're sort of
detecting the epicenter as rapidly as
possible so those in processing time but
then the amount of warning you have is
that processing time minus the travel
time of the seismic energy to get to you
that's right so the farther you are away
the more warning time again it's also
worth pointing out of course that that
means that the people at the epicenter
are not going to get a warning so they
may get a warning sort of borderline
even if they get a warning it's a
fraction of a second warning so that's
unfortunate because obviously people at
the epicenter experience very strong
shaking as well and now forgotten the
second part of your question do we know
where on the fault the earthquakes
rupture the answer's no so I chose that
example of a magnitude 8 on the San
Andreas Fault because it's the one that
gives you the maximum mana warning time
okay so if the that rupture on the San
Andreas Fault initiated which way we're
pointing right offshore of San Francisco
then San Francisco probably would not
get a warning but were actually far
enough away that we would probably get a
warning here but of a second or two
again because we're so close to the
epicenter and we have no basis
scientific basis for being able to guess
where on the fault were more likely to
have an epicenter initiate we know where
they've started in the past but we've
also seen that then in future
earthquakes they tend to start in places
that we didn't expect so sort of equal
probability which starting anywhere on
there fall
okay so so that's individuals that's how
individuals can benefit from early
warning because you prevent these kinds
of injuries but of course there's also
then automated response slowing and
stopping trains is a really big one the
first automated use of earthquake early
warning in the US was actually the BART
train system here they study with
getting our warnings even when it was a
research project and they use it to
automatically slow and then they can
manually stop the trains when there's an
earthquake and they do that because
there can be a thousand people on one of
these trains going along at 70 miles an
hour on one of these raised tracks you
can imagine why they would want to slow
the other application stopping elevators
isolating hazardous machinery hazardous
chemicals data security things like that
okay so how do you get the warnings
there was the question about getting the
warning at the speed of light
essentially but how do you actually get
it to people and the answer to that is
that the vast majority of people they
just want to get the warning on their
smartphone that's the number one way
that people want to get the warning of
course not everybody has a smartphone
but a very large fraction of society now
does have a smartphone and so what might
that look like strong shaking expected
so this is an actual app we actually
have this app I have it on my phone and
so whenever the system detects an
earthquake it pushes out that alert to
to your phone you get that audible
message so you saw what you're saying is
a video of exactly what what I would see
on or get on my phone the audible
message means that despite the fact it's
in my pocket I can hear it and then you
could see that the the app itself it
gives you a countdown and also the
expected intensity of shaking which is
fairly straightforward to calculate once
you know the location and the magnitude
so that's the concept is you push the
warning out to people using this but
also of course you would want to push it
out in as many ways as you can and as
many ways as people want we also have an
app
but you can run the same way on your
desktop computer and it pops up and
makes a a very offensive noise to get
get your attention counts down things
like that but in the long run you can
imagine that these would be sort of the
the goal here is well these have been
built specially for this we want this to
just become embedded in the technology
around us and so it could be the alerts
could come out through your home
security system through the office PA
system and things like that yeah I mean
what's the dangers of absolutely we've
encountered them so let me be very clear
we will always have false alerts the
question is how many false alerts are we
gonna have okay
what are the impact so that's a that's
the important question when it comes to
so right now we're actually in the
process of moving towards a public
rollout they're limited public rollout
later this year and so the discussion is
all about who should have access and you
know how do you roll this out slowly so
we can sort of pilot it without getting
people and pushing it out to everybody
and getting ourselves into into these
kinds of situations part of the reason
the BART train system was such an early
adopter is because they could
automatically slow and stop the trains
they wait 30 seconds they see if
anything's going on and if it is a false
alert they just start the trains up and
if you if you're a local or not but if
you're right on Bart Bart trains do that
all the time
so nobody will even know that there's
been a false alert so you want to start
with situations where the the cost of a
false alert is minimal okay and then as
you build confidence in the system and
as you build accuracy in the system then
you start to expand the number of
applications that you have
they're more generally prior prior
working in this I'm thinking of seat
belt on the light on the airplane right
right right
say pepper chemical industry the more
successful to hard there are their
domains of large which might involve the
general public to the certain extent
that works successful yeah I actually
don't know the answer to that question
one would hope that there is some some
prior art out there but I actually don't
know I don't know what there is I mean I
think that one of the what are the other
pieces is sort of links these two
questions I think is that that I think a
lot of people are much more tolerant of
having false alerts than we might
immediately think and the reason I think
that is after this Mexico City
earthquake a team of us went to Mexico
to to try and fill in this gap as to
what is the public response to warnings
as opposed to a seismologists response
to the warnings and give you a whole
separate lecture on this which obviously
I'm not going to do but they actually
had a pretty they've had a system in
place it did do something you saw a
video the sirens are going off so it's
not like it's not performing but there
are all kinds of limitations to it they
had several false alerts in the run-up
to that significant earthquake when the
significant earthquake happened they
actually only sounded the alarm after
the shaking had started because it was
actually right beneath or kind of right
beneath the city explain in more detail
if you want to afterwards but then when
you go and talk to people they were more
than happy with the system they
understood that the system had its
limitations they understood that there
was some false alerts but they still
were very glad that they had the system
so when it comes to the false alerts
their typical response was well this is
just an opportunity to practice what we
would do to remind ourselves that we
live in earthquake country and what is
it that we're supposed to do when there
is an earthquake and then go through
that kind of drill we even talked to the
CFO of one company he tells us it's the
equivalent of Trader Joe's but he was
ready he wanted devices in the office
buildings and in the supermarkets and he
was quite happy for there to be a false
alert every two months because so to
Milan O'Hara got to two months but in a
two month recurrence interval to remind
people about earthquakes and
practice he thought losing 30 minutes of
work every two months in exchange for
people being much more aware of
earthquakes was was a good thing okay
okay so yes and then there to the next
quest point is that the technology
exists so we'll give slight light relief
for a couple of minutes you don't have
to believe me the technology exists
instead I'm going to have Rachel Maddow
tell you the technology exists thanks to
things like fiber optic cable we can
move information literally in a flash
and that is good you know just the
abstract but that is it turns out
potentially lifesaving
if the information that you are moving
at the speed of light is notification
that an earthquake is about to happen
earthquakes happen in a specific place
in the ground right earthquakes have an
epicenter but you don't just feel an
earthquake at the epicenter the
shuttering waves of motion in the earth
from earthquake they they emanate out
from the epicenter of the quake
traveling at the speed of sound so if
you had the kind of motion sensors that
detected earthquakes if you had
seismometers along fault lines all over
earthquake prone regions when there was
an earthquake
the seismometers nearest to the
epicenter they could register that an
earthquake has happened right feel the
shake and then they could send a digital
signal at the speed of light notifying
communities nearby that this traveling
at the speed of sound tremor this motion
of the earth is about to arrive this is
not a way of predicting earthquakes
before they happen it's a it's a way of
basically warning people that an
earthquake has just happened and that
they are about to feel its effects brace
yourself this thing works scientists at
UC Berkeley say that their shake alert
to earthquake early warning project it
set off an alert it didn't go off this
weekend during this weekend's large
quake in Napa California it was about to
be
in Berkeley and this is the alert that
told them so watch this earthquake
earthquake like shaking expected in 3
seconds they got a 10 second warning
that they were about to feel the quake
in 10 seconds is not much time right but
this this brace yourself warning system
it works thanks to the simple fact that
the speed of light is faster than the
speed of sound and earthquakes only move
at the speed of sound with more sensors
in more places they print presumably
deliver even more warning time
California's hoping to have that bigger
system in place in the next few years
they can get it funded and finished from
the LA Times today once fully developed
the system could give downtown Los
Angeles 40 to 50 seconds of warning that
the big one was headed from the San
Andreas Fault giving time for elevators
to stop at the next floor and open up
for firefighters to open up garage doors
for high-speed trains to slow down to
avoid derailment and for surgeons to
take this out of the patient giving your
surgeon enough time to get the scalpel
out of you before the giant earthquake
starts shaking the operating room that
idea of a tectonic Li shaking scalpel
inside your body somewhere that is
something you can never unknow and I am
sorry about the idea that this warning
technology that it works that it worked
this weekend in fact it's not just on a
drawing board somewhere it is in effect
and it could be expanded and is being
expanded that is an excellent thing
they've got a system like this in Japan
they've got it in Mexico and some other
places around the globe California could
get their whole state wide system done
in a few years
god bless the geeks they will save us
all now it's time for the last word with
lawrence o'donnell hi Lawrence Rachel I
just want them to make the earthquake
warning voice a little less scary music
or something
thank you yeah I don't know the thing
that sticks in my mind in that was all
they could get their systems on in a few
years and you can see this comes in just
after the Napa earthquake we're still
not there yet
however we're not there mainly because
of funding issue is not because of the
science issues there's anyway so this is
a great summary of you know this is how
earthquake early warning works this
shows that it does work we actually did
issue a warning that was our proof of
concept then after earthquake we issued
a warning for the Napper earthquake and
we have been on a trajectory that is
leading to this hopefully limited public
rollout later this year because of this
event because of that proof of concept I
guess so right now we're where is the
system the system is processing data
from the whole west coast so it's using
stations seismic stations from the
various networks that monitor earthquake
activity up and down the west coast I
think it's about I think you actually
this says they turned it but I think
we're up to about a thousand stations
are streaming their data into the system
right now the data is processed at
various centers one of them of course is
here at Berkeley and should have shared
up and down the west coast so it's a
single uniform West Coast wide system
various groups have been getting the
warnings in a sort of prototyping type
mode for a year or so a couple of years
perhaps now including BART as I
mentioned previously but we are really
working towards this limited public
rollout the USGS is the agency that has
the statutory authority to issue
warnings and so they're the ones that
get to define what it means to do a
limited public rollout under pressure
from myself and colleagues at Caltech
and and Washington as to what it should
be but the intent is now that we would
the limited public rollout means pushing
the warning out to teachers in schools
and so the idea is to take that app that
I showed you a few minutes ago and
distribute it to school teachers so that
essentially we can get the warning out
to schools there's all kinds of reasons
that that makes sense that I can go to
into in a few minutes if you would like
but that's that's where that's what the
status
of the of the shakealert project is so
we're about to transition from
shakealert into into my shake but before
I do that I thought I should just spend
three slides the basics of how does
earthquake early warning work how do you
detect earthquakes how do you locate
earthquakes and just so we're all kind
of on the same page earthquake detection
is really simple it's very basic we've
been doing it in exactly the same way
for several decades at this point okay
there's two stages to it first of all
you want to trigger when a seismic
sensor sees that there's something going
on needless to say and so here's the
classic seismogram where you have zero
zero zero zero zero big noise and not
noise big arrival and then then you have
a later arrivals through these two
arrivals which causes some some
complexity but the point is that the
expectation here is that you don't have
noisy data that you have just beautiful
data with with no noise no signal
whatsoever and then you have the the
earthquake occurs you trigger on that
p-wave arrival on individual stations so
you start by recognizing that there's an
earthquake by seeing that there's some
energy arriving at one station and then
you go into stage two which is to
associate the triggers in time and space
obviously if there's an earthquake you
have a whole bunch of seismic stations
that are triggering at the same time so
that's all very simple and
straightforward traditionally the way
that this has been done is using seismic
networks so this is the seismic network
all of the triangles is the seismic
network around the San Francisco Bay
Area it's a very dense network compared
to most parts of the world in fact
compared to most of California as you'll
see in a minute but the point is that
the traditional approach we would wait
for tens or even hundreds of seismic
stations to detect an earthquake and
then you would declare the earthquake
locate the earthquake etc and so the
point is that that takes minutes even
hours using kind of the more standard
traditional approaches to locating
earthquakes but of course for earthquake
early warning we want to do this in a
fraction of a second or just a few
seconds and so we want to be able to
detect seismic arrivals on just one even
once
we don't do that but that would be nice
thing to do just one two three or four
stations and then locate the earthquake
based on that and that's where the
challenge comes in in earthquake early
warning is how do you really build
enough confidence that you really are
detecting an earthquake that rapidly in
order to issue issue the warning so a
couple of examples to show you what some
real data actually looks like so this is
actually from the magnitude for
earthquake I don't know how many people
were here in the Bay Area or in Berkeley
I'm on January the 4th but we had a good
shake on January the 4th it woke me up
in the middle of the night it was a
magnitude 4.4 earthquake the system did
detective and it did push out a warning
and so the way that that that's what
this map is actually from their alert
the initial alert was generated based on
these green triangles they are the ones
that detected the earthquake and we used
to to push out a warning here's a you
know this is a great example it really
does look like there's no noise on these
seismograms so very easy to trigger on
all of these arrivals the what does it
say appear so the alert was pushed out
4.3 seconds after the origin time of the
earthquake the earthquake was actually
at 13 kilometers depth so that means it
takes 2.3 second two point four seconds
for the energy to get to the surface
obviously we can't know about it until
the energy gets to the surface and so
then it took basically took two seconds
for the system to actually detect the
earthquake and push out and push out the
alert which is pretty good but it means
that the area that had already felt the
S waves by the time were pushing out the
alert included most of Berkeley okay
most of Berkeley in most of Oakland over
in San Francisco there was a would have
been all there was a fraction of a
second of warning so that's when it
works okay here's an example that didn't
work so now we're looking further north
in California so you can see what I was
saying about the Bay Area has lots of
stations the rest of California Northern
California does not have very many
stations and that's why we got a false
alert in fact we've had several false
alerts
from this part of the of the state and I
would say that it's driven by the fact
that we don't have enough seismic
stations in the region but then here's
the data so you saw what the data from
the Berkeley earthquake looked like this
is the data that was associated with
this earthquake and so you can see and I
put this just to kind of give an
illustration of some of the challenges
with the with the data of course it's
very easy by I to to see what the issues
are this is obviously some kind of data
glitch with this step function I don't
know what the blue lines are when it
triggers I'm not sure what it triggered
on in this particular case and then
obviously you just have a huge amount of
noise so this the Syst even when you
have a high-quality traditional seismic
Network we still run into these
challenges of noisy data and in fact the
most recent version of the algorithms
has new approaches to try and recognize
the obviously it's very easy to
distinguish between this kind of signal
and this kind of signal but also to try
and remove these kinds of problems as
well but so those just try and give you
a flavor of the data okay so some kind
of triangulation yeah sorry that was I
meant to say that I can say a little
more if you like on this slide but yes
so the way that the earthquakes located
are is it is exactly that it's a
triangulation kind of problem and so you
basically you have the arrival times at
a series of stations we have a velocity
model you don't have to worry about the
details of the velocity model a simple
1d velocity model for the earth is more
than sufficient and just based on the
arrival times you can then determine
that the origin time the location and
the depth of the earthquake that's right
so thinking about that the problem of
the false alerts in the center of
California
it seems like I guess that's partly
caused by the fact that sensors if the
sensors are all equally sensitive then
you have a sparser density of them
around that area then you're more likely
of false alerts right so just that maybe
you want differential accuracy and give
it a fixed budget is that is that
something which is so this is yeah I
mean first of all you know solution
number one is we should have sensors
everywhere there will always be my
number one solution we're going through
a debate about whether you know so does
the initial rollout do we just do just
provide alerts in smaller regions where
we have to in seismic stations or where
we have greater confidence like the
basically that would mean the Bay Area
the Los Angeles area and possibly the
Seattle area but I you know every every
it's of course you know whenever you run
a system like this you see how it
performs and there are always problems
and then you fix those problems and then
there's more problems and I think one of
the issues that we are going to run into
is we were rapidly expanding the network
the networks are now expanding more
rapidly than they ever have previously
other than immediately after big
damaging earthquake cells typically when
they build seismic networks but right
now we're expanding the networks without
having these big damaging earthquakes
and what I foresee happening is that in
fact our algorithms that have become
over the very tuned to the network
geometries that we have we're going to
start running into problems as the
geometry start to change even though
we're adding more stations there are all
kinds of things like the fraction of
start seismic stations we want to
trigger in a certain region and these
have been you know had sort of tuned
manually tuned over the years based on
what we're seeing and what I envision is
that we're going to start seeing
problems with the system just by virtue
of putting in more stations so so to me
one of the challenges we're going to
have is we need to in some way come up
with a much more automated way to be
assessing the performance of the the
network as a whole and tune the alerting
criteria based on that so you could you
know in the way you fix the false alert
problem in that region is you just wait
a little bit longer for more stations to
trigger things like that and but doing
that in some sort of automated way
rather than on an ad hoc way which is
what we do
right now that's a real challenge for us
we don't know how to do that yeah did
you take into account any considerations
of population structure density well so
when it comes to the doing the science
part which is detecting the earthquake
then obviously the population doesn't
matter when it comes to a political
decision about where should we issue the
warnings then of course population does
matter so I'm not sure if you were just
asking about the former or the latter
the social piece so the there's a
there's a discussion going on now as to
whether we're better off to have the
limited public rollout be West Coast
wide even though there are some areas
which have better performance than
others based on the station density and
are we better off doing that saying that
there are limitations to the system and
then maybe we'll see some failures to
the system and that will be argument as
to why the system needs to be improved
or do you only roll it out in certain
areas where you have dense seismic
stations and other people just added
question so over time one of the I don't
have a good answer so I'm going to give
you a half-hearted answer I apologize in
advance everybody thinks that the cost
of seismic networks is buying the
hardware and that is not true the cost
of the seismic network is running the
seismic network which is the ongoing
costs of the telemetry maintaining the
station having people to monitor the
system and catch improvements so if you
look at it like that then clearly the
cost of the instrumentation isn't
significant but but it's not
insignificant we have to still have to
buy it that's the best answer I can give
you on the frame
okay all right so let's move on to so
this is the traditional Network we
really are going to do warnings this
year I believe I mean as in public
warnings limited public warnings this
year I believe but still the system has
issues and the public is going to have
to be ready for some false alerts okay
so shake alert is coming to the west
coast of the US that is great and we're
very excited about that but needless to
say there's a whole lot of the rest of
the world as I mentioned the San
Francisco Bay Area has one of the
densest seismic networks in the world
we're very fortunate in that sense most
of the earthquake prone regions yeah
there's a reason we have the densest
Network maybe that's what that laugh was
for most of the earthquake prone regions
in the world which of the red regions on
this map do not have dense seismic
stations dense seismic networks and so
the question is well what can we do in
the rest of the world and so that's
where my shape comes in and my shake is
all about using the smart phones in your
pockets so as you all know the
smartphone in your pocket has an
accelerometer it's the same sensor that
we use in traditional seismic networks
it's just a whole of lot creamier than
the one that we put out in the in the
traditional network so it's a lot more
noisy already just the the sensor itself
in the phone is a lot more noisy but by
far the most significant problem is
people insist on carrying their phones
around with them all day long
so we have to be able to remove that
signal from any actual earthquake signal
if we want to make use of the the
accelerometer in in people's smartphones
and that's what we're trying to do with
my shake that's the piece that Ching Kai
has figured out how to do so how does my
shake work first of all we want to
harness all of these private smartphones
it's not like other again I just want to
emphasize we're trying to figure out how
to use your smartphone as opposed to
going and buying a whole bunch that
can't tell you how many times people
have said to me why don't you just go
and buy a whole bunch of iPhones and and
you know deploy them out as sensors that
is an incredibly inefficient way to
spend your money to build a seismic
network you can buy much cheaper sensors
than smart phones the whole reason that
this will work is that because there are
obviously millions and millions of smart
phones out there already that we don't
have to buy if we can persuade people to
put our app on their phone and so
therein lies lies the challenge so we
want to make use of in deep private
individual smart phones we want to use
the accelerometer in these smart phones
and to detect an earthquake and then
when it detects an earthquake obviously
it needs to talk to some kind of
back-end so that we can recognize
exactly where the earthquake is and do
real-time analysis and then of course we
could potentially provide warning back
to the the phone operators we can we can
use it to provide warnings our actual
objectives with my Shaykh are much
broader than that we just want to create
a global seismic Network and we can do
all kinds of things with that data so
that data also then gets stored into an
archive that we can be used for any kind
of research and development and I'll
probably forget to say latest let me
just say that right now whenever one of
these phones thinks it's experiencing an
earthquake it records five minutes worth
of data and we archive that five minutes
worth of data although we don't actually
need that data for early warning but the
reason I'm talking about this in the
context of earthquake early warning is
that we think that earthquake early
warning is the motivation for why you
might put this app on your phone right
we obviously need a reason for people to
put it
on their phones so that's the idea
behind my shake so the first challenge
as I've already pointed out is we have
to be able to separate out earthquake
shaking from all other types of shaking
on your phone which of course is is
what's happening most of the time and so
the way that we do this is we have a
classifier analysis this is just running
on an individual phone we use three
characteristics to try and identify
whether it's an earthquake represented
by the red dots here or not an
earthquake the blue dots here and we
find that we use two second windows it's
a newer network based approach [ __ ] I
can tell you all about it he's the one
that created it and it's remarkably
successful at separating earthquakes
from non earthquakes signals based on
our tests we found that it had a 93
percent success rate on the phone of
separating out earthquakes from all of
the other motions that you you put your
firm through so that's the first step is
we on an individual phone we see if we
think it looks like an earthquake and
then if we do think it's an earthquake
we send that trigger what we call the
trigger to our back-end server and the
idea is of course that then on the
backend server you can confirm that it
is another quake so here's an example
some data from this is from the Napa
earthquake gain and so this is just the
classifier analysis that's saying it's
not an earthquake not an earthquake not
earthquake earthquake earthquake
earthquake earthquake to illustrate how
that works again as a mantra if I said
it uses two second windows of data and
and it does this every second so that
does mean that there is some delay in
actually detecting that there is an
earthquake and then here's a much longer
period of time 300 seconds of non
earthquake this is some other human
activity and you can see for the vast
majority of the time it recognizes it's
not an earthquake although it does have
two red dots here so there were two
points in time when it did think it'd
look like an earthquake which is perhaps
not untypical so that's that's kind of
how it works on the phone but then once
it's recognized on the phone we then
want to use a network detection
algorithm to recognize this actually do
an earthquake because we still get it
triggering individual phones triggering
periodically because it's not perfect so
we need to look for a cluster of phones
to trigger in order to confirm that
there's an earthquake can estimate the
location of the earthquake and the
example I'm going to show you actually
comes from this Berkeley earthquake just
a couple of weeks ago that was a great
test for our system in that we have all
of these phones out and I'll tell you
about that in a moment and so we could
see how it actually performed for this
earthquake and so this this is what the
my shape of filaments would look like so
minus one this is the origin time of the
earthquake one two P waves hit the
surface four seconds the red dots are
the phones actually detecting the
earthquake and then when you saw the
star appear and the magnitude appear
that's when the network detection
algorithm confirmed or recognized that
there was an earthquake yeah maybe this
is it sure so you need us a space you
need time and space time I imagine is a
problem but but space depending on what
what's mechanism the API is providing is
that an issue I'm not sure I understand
the question smart phone an issue oh oh
no
so they I mean well obviously we need to
know where the phones are so when we're
doing the lunch I'm asking I understand
the question so obviously we're only
using data from smart phones where we
have the locations of the phones so yeah
so we do need to know the locations and
then how accurate the locations are is
as in within meters is not a concern but
there are dropouts yeah absolutely but
there are dropouts that's right yeah but
yeah I'm gonna let you can ask asked the
same question again in an hour okay so I
think did this keep running so you could
see how it runs a few times oh it looks
like it's stopped let me run it one more
time so hopefully you get a sense
of how again the blue are all of the
phones that we're running at the time of
this earthquake the red or when they
triggered and then the star is when my
Shaykh detected now there's a catch
unfortunately the real time my shake
system did not detect this earthquake
and it should have we do not actually
understand why it didn't detects what
I'm showing you is the result service
offline simulation the triggers are all
real
of course the triggers are the phones
actually triggered and sent their
trigger message but for some reason our
back-end didn't go and associate these
when we run the same algorithm offline
it works so so what we're showing here
is a simulation it didn't actually
happen in real time but that must we
assume that's due to some technical
issue that we haven't managed to figure
out just you okay so that's the idea as
you've already seen we obviously have
rolled out the system because we have
all of those phones for the for the
Berkeley earthquake but this is just to
make the point again that you know we
have almost no seismic data in most
parts of the world again the example
from the pole there's we tried to
estimate how many seismic stations there
are in Nepal and it's somewhere between
0 and 10 that we really cannot get a
good answer on that but there are six
million smartphones so the point is that
even in parts of the world where there
are no seismic stations and you might
not think there's much seismic
infrastructure or in any infrastructure
for that matter the number of
smartphones is really quite remarkable
and so if we can really harness these
smartphones we really think we can do
this in many many parts
so we rolled out an app how many people
in the room have an Android phone Wow
that's better than the usual response
for Berkeley in it globally it's about
50% of people have an Android phone in
Berkeley it's less than 10% so that was
actually a pretty good response rate
it's only available for Android right
now yes we're working on the iPhone
version but if you download the app in
you can get it just go to my shake
berkeley.edu right now it's a citizen
science project okay so you will not get
warnings on your phone nobody gets
warnings right now it's citizen science
you put the app on your phone and you're
basically allowing us to use the
accelerometer on your phone when you're
not doing other things but of course the
intent is that in the future and we will
be able to start providing our warnings
yeah a desktop is more credible for a
stationary position
yeah interesting I'm trying to think why
we haven't seriously considered that
possibility I guess the reason is that
there have been other efforts to use the
the accelerometers actually there's two
parts to the answer
first of all other people have tried to
use the accelerometer in laptop
computers and and they've found they've
been unsuccessful people's interest in
keeping the app so people will be
interested so they'll download the app
that put it on the computer but their
interest rapidly turns over and so then
when they're upgrade their system
whatever they don't upgrade it and so it
no longer is going to work there's a
second problem fewer and fewer laptops
actually have accelerometers in them
today so now that everybody's this has
no accelerometer now as soon as you move
to you know you don't have a disk you
have memory chip all those things thank
you
there's no longer a need for an
accelerometer so there actually aren't
sensors in the modern laptop computer so
this is the device that has the sensor
these don't
every building has a building automation
system or computer California should
mandate that everyone have one no
disagreement here but there's still
there's still more of these I mean I'm
not disagreeing with you yeah no no no I
mean AI actually the reason I got
involved in this project at least five
years ago now was I actually was asked
to do a review of seismic networks
around the world and and these
computer-based networks people have been
trying it as a group at Stanford built
the quake catcher Network a group at Cal
Tech still working on the community
seismic networks they were trying these
low-cost types of networks and so I
wrote this review piece and it was
really interesting to me that that these
low-cost networks were all struggling
because they couldn't maintain the
network that's what somebody asked about
the cost of running networks it's not
the hardware it's the manpower to
maintain the network over time and so
they were all struggling with that plus
they were struggling with the fact that
people's interest wasn't there and so
that led me to thinking well you know
let's go way down you know to the the
poorest quality sensor which is also the
most common sensor in your smartphone
but the other piece is that it is it is
much easier you can put all I have to do
to get and data from your accelerometer
is get you to go to the App Store and
download a piece of software there's no
hardware there's no you know it's that
the system is set up to send the
software to your phone and start
providing data so that's why we started
we started to pursue it but people keep
insisting that there are better places
to put accelerometers I agree but they
haven't done it yet
networking all right it seems to me
that's a challenge you must have to
surmount continuously here is there is
there's a way to use the solutions
you're developing for this problem huh
that's a really great question so I
think that the answer is that we have
not had enough we so we have not issued
any warnings with my shake the Berkeley
earthquake is the first time that our
system should have detect the real-time
system should have detected it but as I
said it didn't for some reason we don't
understand so I guess my answer is that
we have not gotten to the point where
the challenge is dealing with a varying
apology the challenge with my shake is
that we don't have enough phones
I haven't yet shown you how many phones
we have but the reason we haven't
detected more earthquakes is we don't
have enough phones and so so that's the
challenge we I guess we haven't gotten
to that challenge when it comes to the
my shake interesting there in terms of
that using the technology the way that
we're removing some of those false
events from shake alert is by applying
similar kind of techniques to what Ching
Kai developed for the smart phones in
terms of characterizing the arrivals the
p-wave arrivals in order to throw out
some of these false triggers from that
traditional seismic Network just one one
small follow those might suggest is that
there's probably lots of interesting
ways to incentivize adoption of the app
through so for example I concur an
insurance provider and you know people
download Bones for insurance provide a
small discount if you if you also yep
yeah so we've actually talked to the
California earthquake Authority about
about doing that so that as she's an
ongoing conversation that there are
these various routes and you know
frankly this Berkeley earthquake was a
was a turning point for two weeks ago
because it's the first event that we
should have detected up until that point
we were really struggling to show that
we had to an end-to-end system we still
can't prove we have an antenna system
but I have no problem now sitting up and
saying we now know we have all the
pieces in place okay so I still haven't
I'm you know the the punchline here of
course is how many phones have actually
have their app running but you kind of
already know the answer at this point so
this already is by far the largest
seismic network in the world since we
launched we launched in February of 26
so almost two years now well not quite
almost 300,000 people have actually
downloaded the app it's truly a global
network today even you know of course
there was there was a lot of media and
excitement when we launched it so it
wasn't that surprising that we had this
big download it it literally became a
global network over the weekend we
launched it on a Friday was a very
stressful weekend but by Monday we had a
global network with I think about eighty
thousand users two years later we still
have 20,000 active users so we're
actually quite pleased with that and on
any particular day about 7,000 phones
actually send data to our to our
back-end so it's a pretty sizable
network it really is a global network
there are some gaps China is a big gap
and that's because China doesn't have
Google so there's still some of these
kinds of technical challenges that we
will have to work our way through if we
wanted to do a truly global network
it's detected actually this is out of
date I forget how many a [ __ ] I
probably knows almost 800 earthquakes
around the world been detected by by my
sheikh obviously very big ones but also
very small ones magnitude 1.7 earthquake
if you were sat on top of the epicenter
you would not feel that earthquake but
we've actually detected an earthquake as
small as the magnitude one point seven
with with the phones I'm wrapping up
here just to show you a couple of
examples this is our best example in
terms of the number of phones that
detected an earthquake this was a
magnitude 5.2 earthquake in June of 2016
so a few months after we rolled out and
the the radius map works so the
earthquake is here Borrego Springs this
of course is Southern California this is
Los Angeles and San Diego here the the
dots that all of the dots are phones
that were running my shake at the time
of the earthquake okay the red dots are
the phones that were not in ready state
as in somebody was moving them around so
they weren't monitoring for earthquakes
the yellow dots were monitoring for
earthquakes but they did not trigger so
they didn't recognize that they were
experiencing an earthquake and then the
green dots are the ones that did trigger
so they did recognize that they were
experiencing an earthquake and then sent
a trigger message and uploaded data so
about 200 phone's triggered for this
earthquake about a hundred of them
provided what we call good data and data
that you could actually use seismic data
that you could actually use to do an
analysis of this event so to illustrate
what that looks like similar kind of
thing the blue dots are the others the
phones that we're running I'm just going
to run this animation that shows how
they trigger and to guide your eye
you're going to see circles radiating
out just like that animation I showed at
the beginning the P wave and the S wave
and you can see how they're triggering
relative to the to the seismic waves as
they they radiate across across the
region so the yellow is the P wave and
then the red is the S wave I'll let it
run again but you could see as the
energy radiates out this is
Palm Springs area and you can see all of
the or many of these phones trigger as
the P wave comes comes across so they're
actually trigger on the P wave arrived
or that first arriving energy which is
good that gives us more time and when it
comes to so Palm Springs and needless to
say should get further out the fraction
of phones that actually recognize it's
an earthquake shaking decreases and then
the other example is of course this
Berkeley earthquake a little more detail
now so the same kind of map in terms of
the phones so again the piece that's
amazing to me is that this is two years
after we rolled it out so this is pure
citizen science these folks have the app
on their phone because they think this
is an interesting citizen science
project I don't know how many dots there
are on this map but maybe but obviously
several hundred running still running
the app at this point again the the
yellow ones they were monitoring ready
what munching for earthquakes but didn't
trigger the green ones did trigger the
earthquake is up here so of course the
the ratio that triggered to don't
trigger is much higher and up in the
Berkeley area in this case 59 phone
phones triggered 63 phones provided us
with good waveforms so that's telling us
that not all of our triggers are
actually getting to us on the real time
system and then so in animation well
you've seen this animation but I'm going
to show you a different version of it in
a second so this is the one I already
showed you so one second two seconds you
start to see this stations triggering
and then it's located in this simulation
offline version of course and it
estimates a magnitude four point nine
which is pretty good for this particular
earthquake but what I want to show you
is Gainey's ends another one now where I
overlay the P wave and the S wave and
from this particular earthquake so
that's the actual origin time these are
the P waves and the S waves radiating
out and then you can see the stations
the station's triggering in the location
you can see it's a pretty it's a pretty
good location so oops so again the
origin time energy gets to the surface
after two and a half seconds
the phones trigger after four seconds
and then the event is detected so this
is kind of our this is our
proof-of-concept event we think that
this now it's reasonable for us to say
this can actually work and start
providing alerts and so that's actually
what we're working towards as rapidly as
we can at this point oh I just want to
mention and then I'll finish we you can
also use this to monitor buildings I'm
not going to really say much about this
but the sensitivity of the sensors is
good enough to actually measure their
fundamental periods of the building so
you can monitor how the buildings are
shaking and structural engineers are
very interested in this in order to try
and understand where the buildings were
damaged in earthquakes by seeing changes
in the characteristics of the building
so that's another Avenue that's worth
worth looking at
so to summarize the my shake piece you
know we've had this rollout that the
phones are actually doing much better at
detecting earthquakes than we expected
so we're working very hard the number
one the number one question we get is
when's the iPhone version coming out so
we're working very hard to put an iPhone
version out later this year and also
we're working towards doing mornings
interestingly I think the first place
we're going to start doing warnings is
going to be New Zealand they really want
this and they're having a lot of
earthquakes right now so it's a good
kind of match and of course we're
continuing I haven't talked about it at
all but we're using the data for various
research applications as well and while
this is going on so the key challenges
are they they're the same key challenges
I think we've had in seismology for
several decades continues to be first of
all this triggering on the earthquake
how do you really tell that you're
seeing an earthquake just at an
individual sensor and then and
separating it out from noise obviously
particularly now that we're using these
phones and then associating these
clusters of triggers and it's the same
challenge whether we're talking about
shake alert on my shake we still face
the same challenge that's this main
source of of errors is that part of the
system
in terms of the outlook the outlook for
shaker that's pretty good it's a proven
technology I think we will have a public
warning system the face is there because
this is really about the funding piece
and I was very careful how I chose the
third picture but I can tell you we went
through a bit of a bump the Trump budget
cut shakealert out completely but
Congress is actually putting it back in
of course we don't have a final budget
yet but the budget legislation that is
again on hold for another two weeks or
whatever as of noon today is actually
has shakealert put back into it so
Trump's budget try to take it out but
Congress has put it back in and I think
that's a really good measure of the what
we've been able to demonstrate to
Congress about the capabilities of
shakealert and then my shake I think is
really is just getting started I think
it is a research project but I really
think you could have a global impact
okay I'm going to stop there and I'm
happy to answer questions and if they
get too technical I'm going to tell you
to ask King Kai yeah
how many events who we will detect but
on the flip side how many kind of alarms
for my shake so my shake has created
zero false alarms when we go back and we
do this again we haven't detected any
events in real time either okay but when
we go back and we run the simulation
through the you know our simulated
system we should have detected most of
them and we didn't detect because we
were not running the real-time detection
algorithm but we would have detected
four events so over the course of the
two years that we've been running my
shake since the public release we would
have detected four events we should have
detected four events and there would
have been zero false alerts same the
same question for shake alert as you
don't know what the ratio is there
there's many many more real events than
there are false events we we really
worry about the false events and so
we're talking about onesie twosie when
it comes to false events ones that one
or two events it's it's I know it sounds
like an ik and I'm making an excuse but
it is really difficult to characterize
exactly what you mean by false alert
right okay so it depends on whether you
mean the magnitude was off by more than
half a magnitude unit 1 magnitude unit
the location is off by more than five
kilometers 10 kilometers or there's no
earthquake whatsoever
okay now when you say no earthquake
whatsoever do you mean no earthquake
anywhere on the globe I and the reason I
say that is that the main source of
false alerts for shakealert has actually
been large
telepsychic earthquake so magnitude
seven or eight earthquakes on the other
side of the globe that still trigger all
of our stations they actually have
amplitudes that are not that different
to some smaller earthquakes when they're
big earthquakes and they're deep
earthquakes so our problem in the past
has actually been false alerts due to
these telepsychic events so you could
call that a there was no real earthquake
but you see my point
and I think we've had I'm going to throw
out a number maybe five per year of with
magnitude estimates of about four so you
don't end up with really large magnitude
errors large magnitude estimates but you
end up with fours so you would push out
the alerts for those but but
transmitting in the lerp states through
a network so forth probably use it
really that's right what is this so S
waves which carry most of the damage
traveled at about three and a half
kilometers per second okay so that's one
estimate that's one source of time delay
until the actual shaking occurs when it
comes to the speed with which we can
push out these warnings we find so
there's the actual detect the processing
of the the the seismic processing is
negligible the delays are the the
traditional network typically sends
one-second packets of data so you wait
one second and then you send that chunk
of data you wait one second so on
average that's a half second delay
depending on where the arrival is right
in that one second packet the actual
transmission time of that data it varies
from a few tenths of a second to a few
seconds in some word in some of the
older stations but an average might be
about half a second so a good typical
time between when an event a seismic
arrival has hit a station and when our
system can recognize it is about a
second let's say on average notable time
to process it but then you have to push
the warning out to people we have far
less data on how long that actually
takes because we need to measure how
long it takes for the thing to get to
your phone or to your computer but our
best guesses at that is one to two
seconds to put that in context everybody
thinks about the Amber Alert System
can't you push it out over the AMBER
Alert System the weir system
that actually takes tens of seconds so
the the current technology they use for
that is not fast enough along with
perspective maybe just shake alerts what
what would performance p4 aftershocks
where perhaps rescue teams really can
can benefit from yeah from a poor way
and then with confidence absolutely so
so yes and it's also the kind of
situation where the tolerance for false
alerts is also lower or higher or it's
better like you can looser thank you
but it's also very challenging time in
terms of seismic network detection
because in an aftershock situation you
have many earthquakes occurring in very
close succession so the Association part
of the problem becomes much more
challenging because you can have
stations in different parts of the
region triggering and you think they're
coming from the same earthquake but
they're actually two separate
aftershocks that are occurring just a
few seconds apart in different locations
so for example in Japan has an early a
public early warning system that pushed
out a warning successfully for the
magnitude 9 to haki worth quake in 2011
it was a big deal but then in the
aftershock period in their sort of weeks
so I think it was afterwards they had
several the incidents where they had
magnitude 7 false alerts which were due
to the miss association of arrivals from
different triggers so the I would say
that in their aftershock time period I
would agree with you entirely that
that's a really good time for really
warning because people are much more
tolerant of these kind of false alerts
but you also get more false alerts as
well
is there are there other technologies
for tsunami formation tsunami alert I
mean to satellite they don't know so
there's tsunami warnings that you hear
about on the news are for warnings of
tsunamis that are going across the
entire ocean base and across the Pacific
Ocean so then there's ours right so so
if we're worried about an earthquake in
Japan causing a tsunami that affects
California we're talking about I think
is 10 hours travel time so there's lots
of time to play with if you want to
worry about the tsunami if there's an
earthquake in Cascadia offshore of
Seattle and you're worried about the
effect of the tsunami up and down the
Washington coast there there are almost
no warning systems capable of doing that
because there's no systems that can
detect it quickly enough the only way of
doing it is to take shakealert and
extend it so so what I haven't talked
about here is that we have more
sophisticated algorithms for larger
magnitude earthquakes that actually not
only estimate the origin point and time
of the earthquake and it's going to they
also estimate the total area of the
fault that's ruptured now once you do
that so that takes a little more time so
it takes another 5 seconds 10 seconds
but once you do that you can use that to
predict what you might expect for a
tsunami if it's a subduction zone
earthquake and so we find that you would
be able to provide information about a
tsunami in about a minute and it
typically takes 5 to 10 minutes for the
tsunami wave from in the case of Seattle
for an earthquake offshore of Seattle to
hit the coast so so there's actually
real value to extending what is
earthquake warnings in order to do this
tsunami warnings I flippantly tell
people that if you do earthquake early
warning you get tsunami warning for free
you mean or not even a phone if you just
have a sensor and that sensor see
something and it sounds an alert yeah so
it has the advantage of simplicity
clearly that's a big deal but of course
the sensor so now the question is are
you going to try and detect the p-wave
and issue a warning before the s-wave or
are you just going to wait for the to be
significant shaking and then sound an
alarm and so if you know if you wait for
significant shaking and sound the alarm
well the person probably felt that
shaking as well there still is some
value to that to be clear because what
we will what people who study these
things have seen very clearly is people
start to feel shaking and we all look at
one another is I don't know do you feel
bad I'm not sure what should I do do we
do we do now if an alarm goes off and he
says earthquake and you know when I hear
that alarm I get down between these
chairs that so there's value to that but
there's no it's difficult to imagine a
scenario where you get warning before
you start to feel the shaking yourself
so that limits the value like this yeah
so you're focused on damaged and danger
to persons and property would have been
absolutely correctly of course but my
recollection from the Loma Prieta
earthquake and it's aftershocks was that
the it was the aftershocks not the
initial earthquake that were
psychologically wearing on me and the
people around me they continued the
going on for weeks and weeks these
father you know magnitude five have you
can have you have you considered
especially with respect to aftershocks
whether P whether at best and that
whether people are going to be more or
less psychologically affected by the
receiving a warning or not there have
been no studies of that but I I would
agree with you I you know obviously I'm
an advocate for earthquake early warning
I feel like I'm three times during a
battle with colleagues my seismology
colleagues who get incredibly focused on
we can't have any false alerts and the
estimate the accuracy of the information
we provide has to be perfect
and and what about the after shop
problem people are really concerned
about false alerts for aftershocks and
my I would argue which is exactly to
your point that the for people for
people who are experienced in the
earthquake and we've seen and we and I'm
not just making this up this is a game
what we've learned from Mexico and also
from New Zealand in when the your
aftershock point when people have just
had a big earthquake there's a complete
feeling of helplessness that that this
thing that we consider to be you know
rigid and fixed it's not it could all
collapse kind of thing and so providing
having a warning system provides some
sense that we're doing something about
it even if that actual warning system
may not be performing particularly well
I think that's what we heard in the
commentary we got from the the public
that we interviewed after the next week
so I would put that into what I think of
has been kind of the broader benefits of
earthquake early warning are helping
people through that what is a very
traumatic situation are helping people
to think about the earthquake before it
happens increase their rates with which
people prepare for earthquakes and so
those are the sort of you know we're
increasing one of my social scientist
colleagues calls this the seismic
culture we're enhancing the seismic
culture by which people are aware of the
problem and they understand what they
can do in order to reduce the impacts
and they actually take actions as
opposed to just being I'm just not going
to think about it so I have a break
could be sure good point
absolutely yes okay so I'm happy to keep
answering questions out out the back I'm
afraid I can't stay for the rest of the
afternoon [ __ ] I can answer questions
as well later this afternoon
[Applause]